Core values
Spoken word poetry
Godly
Humane and nationalistic
At the beginning of life
Let's face the god who gave
Every trial and obstacle in our journey
Let's hope that god always is
Supporting
He is the true creator of man
It comes from his blood and heart
I hope so
Let's be humane
And avoid being cunning
Because it has no good to glean
If the world will have a conflict
How can we work together
If we ourselves are the cause of the chaos
Let's think about nature
If it's peaceful it's good to watch
This is where the
Real wealth
That is never irreplaceable
Let's be nationalistic
When united
We have hope
We can enjoy every joy
And only love for each other
This is where wisdom is expressed
Ability to
Let's shine
Gaining clarity
To in life
At the same time
We will fight